Oh beautiful beautiful music am i
beautiful
no have you ever cut hair before yeah in
second grade I was trying to cut out a
tag on my shirt the razor there's me wet
like this and I cut my front hair here
because I didn't have bangs but I
thought I did and my mom saw me and
she's like what did you teach your
eyebrow where all this hair come from
and that didn't work out do you think it
would be easy to cut here Wow if we're
allowed to go fun with it then yeah
it'll be easy
hi I'm Tyra Tyra nice to meet you so do
you want your hair done I do what kind
of haircut do like I'm gonna leave it up
to you you know I would love a dramatic
haircut how about a bouquet well you
pixie you're gonna cut it all off
shopping your hair okay let's hope it's
not giving in to cancer don't work oh
okay and we're gonna make this nice and
short I'm pretty sure I know what I'm
doing
how's your day going you know it's good
getting over to cold but oh yeah then
we're gonna snip that snip over here you
have a boyfriend I do have a boyfriend
can I steal it he needed this so glad
she came in they're just gonna keep
sniffing oh yeah oh okay
doing fine it's gonna be about three
hundred dollars
whoa yeah well we do a very good cut
feel like there's artistry happening
behind me and I don't even know it yet
well perfection actually perfection is
happening so kind of gossip is there
listen on Friday I stole a bunch of
orange juice from this office what your
hair's went to six did your mom give you
this hair
how many boyfriends do you have only one
and you're not that pretty
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding what's
the hot gossip at your office buddy
there's this girl mmm
well secretly cause between you and me
no okay I don't think this is even but
people's hair do not need to be even oh
that was a close one
I heard that one Tyra how many
boyfriends do you have at polar tell me
everything what is the backstory
she's they'd like to love my life I
can't wait till you see it you sure it's
all hairy we didn't have a like a salon
wrap or whatever those things are called
because you're poor gonna get some bangs
if you cut the face off then they're
probably not gonna pay you and then
you're gonna need a lawyer and then
you're gonna go to court it's escalated
very quickly by making a lot of hair on
me Tyra then you go in the shower wash
it off
why don't I think of that because you
have no brain yeah this is how you treat
all your customers Tyra okay I think I
owe you different actually it looks kind
of ugly how much she gonna pay me for
doing this like $100 $10 worth every
penny
for that the hair is ophea yep free
sweater
oh I'm beautiful look at that dude this
is so good holy moly look at this oh my
goodness Wow actually this isn't bad I
don't think this is a bad look honestly
I kind of look like Taylor Swift right
you look amazing thank you
this is very modern this is very chic I
see why you're so expensive oh thank you
you're welcome
what a wonderful haircut you're welcome
I do I will say that I am covered in
hair I would like that to play whenever
I enter a room please it's over